El solucionador variacional cuántico de eigenvectores, o VQE, es uno de los primeros algoritmos híbridos cuántico-clásicos y es
interesante por varias razones. Primero, como veremos en este video, es un enfoque prometedor para algunos tipos de problemas. En segundo lugar, es importante
históricamente y ha allanado el camino para muchos algoritmos mejorados como el adapt VQE.
Y por último, el VQE es bastante simple. Es fácil entender qué hacen las computadoras cuánticas y clásicas en este algoritmo
y cómo interactúan. Hay cuatro componentes principales en un cálculo de VQE.
Primero, hay un operador, a menudo un Hamiltoniano, que llamaremos H, que describe una propiedad del sistema que
queremos optimizar. Otra forma de decirlo es que buscamos el eigenvector de este operador que
corresponde al eigenvalor mínimo. A ese eigenvector lo llamamos comúnmente el estado base.
Luego, hay un ansatz, palabra que significa aproximación. Este es un circuit cuántico que prepara un estado cuántico aproximando
el eigenvector que buscamos. En realidad, el ansatz es una familia de circuits cuánticos porque algunos de los gate en
el ansatz están parametrizados. Es decir, se les alimenta un parámetro que podemos variar. Esta familia de circuits cuánticos
puede preparar una familia de estados cuánticos que aproximan el estado base.
A continuación, necesitamos un estimador, un medio para estimar el valor de expectación del operador H sobre el estado variacional
cuántico actual. A veces, lo que realmente nos importa es simplemente este valor de expectación, que
llamamos función de costo. Otras veces nos importa una función más complicada que aún puede escribirse partiendo de
uno o más valores de expectación.
Finalmente, necesitamos un optimizador clásico, un algoritmo que varía los parámetros para intentar minimizar esta función de costo.
Vamos a describir el problema que queremos resolver y el enfoque general antes de ver cómo interviene lo cuántico. Podemos
formular muchos problemas de optimización críticos para la ciencia y la industria como problemas de valores matriciales. Comúnmente,
queremos el eigenvalor mínimo de nuestra matriz y el eigenvector que le corresponde. La matriz H podría ser
un Hamiltoniano que describe la energía de un sistema físico. Y el eigenvalor mínimo sería la energía del estado base
E0, y el eigenvector sería el estado base cuántico correspondiente, a menudo denotado como psi sub cero.
O la matriz podría describir una función de costo complicada asociada con problemas de optimización combinatoria,
como en logística, y el eigenestado s subópt sería una solución óptima del
problema, como una cadena binaria que etiqueta un corte en un grafo de una red de distribución. En la práctica,
es común escuchar el término Hamiltoniano para todas las matrices de interés, incluso fuera de las ciencias físicas. Supongamos que
nos interesa una matriz con n filas y n columnas. Este tipo de problemas se puede resolver rápida y exactamente usando
solvers clásicos para n de hasta unos pocos cientos o miles, sin ninguna suposición sobre la matriz. Para matrices
dispersas, aquellas con mayormente ceros como entradas, esto puede ser mucho mayor, con n hasta mil millones, incluso en una laptop.
Pero para problemas verdaderamente enormes que superan esas cifras, a menudo se requieren métodos aproximados o heurísticos.
Cuanto más grande es la matriz y menos dispersa, menos tratable es el problema y más trucos ingeniosos hay que emplear. Supón que tu matriz es tan
grande que la diagonalización exacta no es una opción. Supón además que sabes lo suficiente sobre tu problema como para
hacer algunas suposiciones sobre la estructura general del estado objetivo y quieres explorar estados similares a tu
estimación inicial para ver si tu costo o energía puede reducirse aún más. Este es un enfoque variacional y es un método
que se usa cuando la diagonalización exacta no es una opción usando una computadora clásica. Funcionaría de la siguiente manera.
Primero, haces un estado inicial con algunos parámetros theta que vas a variar.
Aunque esta estimación inicial podría ser aleatoria, eso no es aconsejable. Queremos usar el conocimiento del problema en cuestión
para ajustar nuestra estimación tanto como sea posible.
Segundo, calcularíamos el valor de expectación del operador con el sistema en ese estado.
Tercero, alteraríamos los parámetros variacionales y repetiríamos.
Cuarto, usaríamos la información acumulada sobre el paisaje de estados posibles en tu subespacio variacional para hacer estimaciones cada vez mejores
y acercarnos al estado objetivo.
El principio variacional garantiza que nuestro estado variacional no puede producir un eigenvalor menor que el del
estado base objetivo. Por lo tanto, cuanto menor sea el valor de expectación, mejor es nuestra aproximación del estado base.
Hablemos de la dificultad de cada paso en este enfoque.
Establecer o actualizar parámetros es computacionalmente fácil. La dificultad está en seleccionar parámetros iniciales útiles
motivados físicamente. Usar la información acumulada de iteraciones anteriores para actualizar los parámetros de tal manera
que te acerques al estado base no es trivial. Pero existen algoritmos de optimización clásica que lo hacen
de forma bastante eficiente. Esta optimización clásica solo es costosa porque puede requerir muchas
iteraciones. En el peor de los casos, el número de iteraciones puede escalar exponencialmente con n.
El paso individual más costoso computacionalmente es casi con certeza el valor de expectación de tu matriz usando un
estado dado. La matriz de n por n debe actuar sobre el vector de n elementos, lo que corresponde a del orden de n cuadrado
operaciones de multiplicación en el peor de los casos. Esto debe hacerse en cada iteración de parámetros. Para matrices
extremadamente grandes, esto tiene un alto costo computacional. Ahora imagina delegar esta parte del
cálculo a una computadora cuántica. En lugar de calcular este valor de expectación, lo estimas preparando el
estado s de theta en la computadora cuántica usando tu ansatz variacional y luego haciendo mediciones.
Analicemos eso un poco. H generalmente no es fácil de medir. Por ejemplo, podría estar compuesto de muchos
operadores de Pauli x, y y z que no conmutan.
Pero H puede escribirse como una combinación lineal de términos H subalpha, cada uno de los cuales es fácilmente medible. Por ejemplo,
operadores de Pauli o grupos de operadores de Pauli que conmutan bit a bit. El
valor de expectación de H sobre el estado S es la suma ponderada de los valores de expectación de los términos constituyentes H alpha.
Esta expresión es válida para cualquier estado s, pero la usaremos específicamente con nuestro estado variacional s de theta.
Cada uno de los términos h alpha puede medirse m veces, produciendo muestras de medición s subalpha j, con j que va de
1 a m, y devuelve un valor de expectación y una desviación estándar. Podemos sumar
estos términos y propagar los errores a través de la suma.
Esto no requiere multiplicaciones a gran escala ni ningún proceso que escale necesariamente como n cuadrado. En cambio,
requiere múltiples mediciones en la computadora cuántica. Si no necesitas demasiadas, este enfoque podría ser
eficiente. Y esa es la parte cuántica del VQE. Pero hablemos de las razones por las que esto podría no ser eficiente. Una razón
para muchas mediciones es reducir la incertidumbre estadística en tus estimaciones para cálculos de muy alta precisión.
Otra razón es el número de cadenas de Pauli necesarias para abarcar toda tu matriz. Dado que las matrices de Pauli más la
identidad abarcan el espacio de todos los operadores de una dimensión dada, tenemos garantizado
que podemos escribir nuestra matriz de interés como una suma ponderada de operadores de Pauli, como hicimos antes. Aquí, C alpha es un
coeficiente numérico y H alpha es una cadena de operadores de Pauli que actúan sobre todos los qubits que describen tu sistema.
H alpha tendría una forma como esta, donde el n-ésimo operador de Pauli desde la derecha actúa sobre el n-ésimo qubit. Así que podemos
medir nuestro operador midiendo una serie de operadores de Pauli. Pero no podemos medir todos esos operadores de Pauli
simultáneamente. Los operadores de Pauli, excluyendo la identidad, no conmutan entre sí si están
asociados con el mismo qubit. Por ejemplo, podemos medir I Z IIZ y ZZ
XZ simultáneamente porque podemos medir I y Z al mismo tiempo para el tercer
qubit. Y podemos conocer I y X simultáneamente para el primer qubit. Pero no podemos
medir todos los Z y ZZ ZX simultáneamente porque Z y X no
conmutan y ambos actúan sobre el qubit cero.
Entonces descomponemos nuestra matriz H en una suma de Paulis que actúan sobre distintos qubits.
Algunos elementos de esa suma pueden medirse todos a la vez. A esto lo llamamos un grupo de Paulis que conmutan. Dependiendo de
cuántos términos no conmuten, puede que necesitemos muchos de esos grupos. Llamemos al número de esos grupos de Paulis que conmutan
ngcp.
Si ngcp es pequeño, esto podría funcionar bien.
Si h tiene millones de grupos, no será útil. Registras el valor de expectación o la función de costo
para el conjunto de parámetros theta usados en tu estado y luego actualizas los parámetros con el tiempo. Puedes usar los
valores de expectación o los valores de la función de costo que has estimado para aproximar un gradiente de tu función de costo en el
subespacio de estados muestreados por tu ansatz.
Existen optimizadores clásicos tanto basados en gradiente como libres de gradiente. Ambos sufren de posibles problemas de entrenabilidad, como
múltiples mínimos locales y grandes regiones del espacio de parámetros con gradiente casi nulo, llamadas mesetas yermas.
¿Entonces el VQE resolverá todos tus problemas más difíciles? No. Pero ser mejor en todos los cálculos nunca fue el objetivo.
Hemos desplazado lo que determina el costo computacional. Mira lo que hemos intercambiado. Pasamos de un proceso
cuya complejidad depende solo de la dimensión de la matriz a uno que depende de la precisión requerida y del número de
operadores de Pauli no conmutantes que componen la matriz. Esta última parte no tiene análogo en la computación clásica.
Basándonos en estas nuevas dependencias, para matrices dispersas o matrices con pocas cadenas de Pauli no conmutantes, este
proceso puede ser útil. Este es el caso para sistemas de espines interactuantes. Por ejemplo, para matrices densas, puede ser
menos útil. Sabemos, por ejemplo, que los sistemas químicos a menudo tienen Hamiltonianos que involucran cientos, miles, incluso
millones de cadenas de Pauli. Se ha hecho trabajo interesante para reducir este número de términos, pero
los sistemas químicos pueden estar mejor adaptados a algunos de los otros algoritmos que discutiremos en este curso.
El uso efectivo del VQE también requiere que conozcas los atributos de tu estado objetivo y puedas seleccionar un buen estado inicial
motivado físicamente, así como un buen ansatz con relativamente pocos parámetros variacionales. Esto puede ser
bastante desafiante. El VQE demuestra cómo se pueden combinar las fortalezas de las computadoras clásicas y cuánticas
sin añadir métodos más recientes. El VQE no nos ayuda a resolver problemas que son intratables para las computadoras clásicas, pero
sigue desempeñando un papel en el desarrollo de algoritmos. Y el VQE también nos enseña que transferir un paso de las computadoras clásicas
a las cuánticas no es ni mejor ni peor para todos los propósitos. Más bien,
cambia qué factores determinan la eficiencia de tu algoritmo. Esta es una lección general importante en la computación
híbrida cuántico-clásica.